relation to fallout
I've spent most of the past week sitting
on the toilet
playing fallout shelter you guys still
playing no I picked that but like right
when it came out III to like capture
some gameplay and I was half distracted
I think this is the shitty gameplay I
captured and like too many things
happening I was like I don't know I
can't deal with this game right now the
way it is so [ __ ] cartoony this isn't
be fallout come on oh no it looks great
like that that art style the way the it
shifts when you move it is like giving
that fake 3d look mm-hmm yes but I feel
like the more I play it doesn't really
change like I'm still just kind of doing
the same thing over and over it's just
management time management at that point
yeah this is kind of like real life
boring I do management things already
I've got to have 45 people in mine at
the moment I had a real bad time there
for a while when nothing was working and
I had to like spend a good like two
hours just stopping everyone from being
infected with radiation because the
water wasn't working yeah but now it's
like growing up and there's this thing
where you can send them out to the
wasteland yes and this sounds cool I
didn't get to this it's cool but if you
don't recall them they're like I send
them out like loads of stimpaks
and they basically pick up a shitload of
guns and like and well that's how you
get all your equipment guns and outfits
for your carriage and they have fits are
the best because they give you perks I
didn't realize for the longest time that
they gave you Park so I was like holding
on to them doing nothing and but my guys
always die so I end up just piss pic
sending a match paying they're like
revive fee and then getting them to come
back again just like waiting to see how
much they get before they die and then
pulling them back in but all this stuff
all like the training centers that kind
of takes a long time to like pop people
into these rooms and gonna make them
grow and charm and look and all that
sort of stuff but you're right it kind
of feels like it doesn't really have an
end so what an end it would be if this
[ __ ] pulled into Fallout 4 at the end
yeah did you imagine that many people
tried that right like doing sad games on
like Xbox Live whereas like oh but all
your money carries over to fable
whatever yeah I know oh yeah or what if
this like what if this made an outpost
like you could find whatever won't you
made all four twenties out there I think
vault 420 probably already Z I have I
have a family in there called in Newtons
and I've named every one of their
child's fig so I love the idea that like
I'll just turn like they don't even tell
you
it looked like your vault somewhere like
they tie it to the phone and then you're
evolved to someone I walk in and it's
like that Gary one where everyone's like
Gary I was going except they're all
called Fig Newton and they were all
infected yeah yeah I don't know I'm
gonna keep playing a little bit longer
let's see if they see if they keep
updating it it was definitely like a fun
little game to play during e3 when
you've got no time when you're managing
your own when you were you know we're
not busy anyway so no not at all and now
there's nothing going on that's true
that's the best part it's the best part
of the year you get to catch up and all
your wit your stuff yeah yeah wait I'm
coming up and I'm off to games come
pretty soon as well and Justin and Andy
hug you so much coming on talk about
fallout for doody thanks for having
gonna be doing that a lot over the next
coming weeks and months